the Nobel week was a unique experience
in many ways I mean it was like being on
cloud 11 for the whole week and a lot of
lot of publicity of course it was on the
one hand the Swiss maid actually I
mentioned before they we had 24-hour
coverage essentially by the Schweitzer
illustrate them which would then make
very long reports on the holes and
pictures to the swiss television every
day so on but in addition there were two
japanese laureates the same year Tanaka
and physicist whose name I cannot recall
right now and so there were of the order
of a hundred and forty Japanese
reporters here and Tanaka was mostly
locked up in his room because he was
completely over held and the physicist
was much older than I NT he also had to
be very low key and because I most time
grazi well known in Japan you see I just
got the Kyoto price they they they have
videos of me which I played on
television so the Japanese report just
started to come down on me and I didn't
have access to the Japanese laureates so
it was a very intense week and palate
rows of God hits greatest weekend
scientists life i think i may also add
that i have been back three times since
and it is much more leisure much more
eating and drinking you are here as a
visitor rather sad mad you are a
laureate